hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to year walk a game that
came out a few months back but a lot of
people have been requesting that I play
it now it's a little different than most
of the games that I've played it does
seem to be a bit of horror but I've been
walking around a bit round here and it's
got that kind of knock-knock esque going
forward and backwards mechanic except
that I think I'm in a first-person view
and I don't know what to do just yet but
so bear with me as soon as I figure this
out because this game is totally new to
me and I will be doing a full
playthrough of it so prepare for a lot
of story going on yes that was a thing
but I need to find if there's a thing
that I can do around here that makes
more sense in what I was doing back
there aha
here we go I'll be back to that in just
a second but there's a few landmarks
around this pure white snow scape that
are intriguing now we're starting to get
in dairies that I have no idea where now
this game does have a little bit of
aspect of horror to it now I'm not sure
how much that got close really quickly
there also it sounds eerily rickety
don't know if I can go up to Ojai well
okay then didn't know there were other
people around you there you are I've
been waiting for you all day why I have
no idea why smiling so I assume I'm not
a murderer you should not go outside
without a hat on a cold day like this
you will freeze your ears off and I'm
quite fond of the person those ears
belong to ah
aren't you sweet did anyone see you
coming here not sure why that's relevant
to the situation you're now you're being
silly
you know that I'm not ashamed of you
it's not that I like you very much but
you and I come from different worlds
he's waiting my answer
poor man sir I said I'd give it to him
next year and this is the last day of
this year now I know there's gonna be a
very story-based game now you're being
unfair this isn't any easier for me what
is going on I don't like it when you're
like this
calm down you're walking hope you're
joking you do remember what happened to
my cousin don't you maybe promise me you
won't do anything foolish we are not
supposed to know what happens in the
future you should hurry home to your
cottage and get some rest
it's getting dark soon hurry home to
your cottage you should probably go
you should really hurry home now is
something gonna happen if I stay it's
getting dark soon okay so I do have a
map here I do that would have been much
more helpful because I had no idea where
I was going I did not know there was a
map I apologize for the state of my hair
I just got off of a huge recording
session with Bob wait Jack so I should
probably go now I can take a hint after
the 16th time that's when I really get
it through my big thick skull so anyway
I need to get back to where I was before
there's that box if the box is some sort
of combination thing I played with it
for a little bit but I don't know the
combination maybe this has something to
do with your walking and when I actually
find out what I need to do in a year
walk that's gonna help me but I assume
that you're walking involves forces that
I'm not supposed to be messing with and
I might unlock the dangerous potential
of the north I don't know it's either
way well okay oh I'm going towards it if
I'm just passing out in the snow and
that's very bad so I don't know who that
was it didn't even seem to say what now
oh that's interesting so I didn't mean
to do that
is that important okay
what is going on here what are these
mean am I supposed to find the
particular items okay so that's a key
there's got to be something that's part
of the windmill I was just at and I
think I saw a wheel barrel in the snow
oh I'm spilling out the go my god I'm
spelling out the game this is the logo
of the game holy crap that's cool oh my
god I don't think that's as cool as I
think it is but good that's cool you
walk can't go backwards can't go
forwards Kate what was that oh I was
missing a letter I'm a dumb-dumb okay I
wasn't totally done I thought it was
done never mind I'm just an idiot
here we go doing the year walk to find
out what's going on in the future or
something like that I don't know did I
already do it seems to be a bit darker
and creepier in these woods oh why am I
doing this why again do I need to go
back to see the lady with a girl I don't
know what does that like yeah if I could
speak English wait whoa oh there's
another cool do I need to write these
down the spirit of the girl flies over
the sea the cent sign as in this girl
doesn't make any sense isn't pretty sure
what that's trying to get it hello you
still here no she is not well then where
the hell am I supposed to go I am lost I
have no idea what is happening here let
me check my map so OH all my map is
suddenly revealed now so let me go to
that building over there the church
seems to be kind of important so I'm
just assuming been again I don't know
anything that's going on in this game
just yet whoa what's that what is that
why does it keep popping up into the
bottom of my screen I would really like
to see that
oh oh it's the goat key
I need the goat key to open that gate so
I got okay hi lady and who might you be
so what I'm interpreting from that is I
need to find the lady hidden in the
woods hidden beneath the trees in
between the snow banks who is hiding the
key I need in order to be able to go to
the church so I'm gonna be a wandering
around for quite a bit apparently was
there anything else beyond no the
windmill was the last stop on that so
okay then I have no idea what's going on
and I love a game when it puts me into a
world where I have no idea what's going
on because exploring is half of the part
of a game especially when it comes to
something like this you need what is
that okay I'm done exploring what the
hell is that what in the world
ooh why why do oh oh I can look
uh-huh that's very disturbing okay so I
screwed its head on it's no okay
ah Oh much rather not
geez okay you're weird you're very weird
okay this is a code right left right
left left right
wait you're pointing to the doggies on
the wall so I don't know what this means
I think oh oh no no no you can't do that
to me no no no no no no no I can't veto
on this this bunch of okay it's gone I
didn't know that was a whole bunch of
fun but I'd rather not do that ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever again okay
so there's a camp also in the back area
where I just came from what in the hell
cuz I was telling me something that I
needed to know I know that was a clue
but I don't know what it was a clue to
anybody home no nobody's home huh okay
how long do I need to stay in this
hellhole
I'll leave no I'll leave you can stay
I'll leave where else can I go and go
forward into the right and back oh no
wait
what from the back of the what from the
back of the tent that leads over to oh
maybe it's owes it it's it's a tunnel or
something like that oh I needed like a
source of light to be able to navigate
through it or something I've no idea if
that's correct but I'm gonna so assume
did I make a wrong - oh that was
supposed to go that way okay but there
must be a path back here we go
what are you why are you look like
nipples what is going on I can't read
that
what's with the goats gotta do something
throat of demonic sacrifice here
what is all hi whoa Jesus god damn it
you can't sneak up on a guy like that hi
lady I need you no lady where you going
lady lady lady look at me um lady of the
forest
you're leaving weird afterimages
freaking me out
you got twigs coming out of your back
you sing beautifully though just the
most beautiful thing singing I've ever
heard but I I can't move okay I can't
move anymore
what are you doing okay then I supposed
to follow you I'm assuming lady where
are you leading me I kind of want to
sing with you but it wouldn't be nearly
as beautiful okay so you're gonna go
that way
you're leading me into my doom aren't
you you're leading me deeper into the
woods and this is how people die things
out people die in the horror games and
movies I've seen him I've lived them oh
no you're walking me to the path ah my
little vision told me that you had the
key you're revealing the path aney yes
yes please I will follow
look she's nice she's so nice she's so
nice to me thank you oh this is the oh
this is the puzzle oh this is the puzzle
I need to go ah ah I need to go listen
to the oh that was mildly creepy okay
you Hooters there you stay there I'm
gonna be right back I'm gonna go
memorize a puzzle okay here we go left
right left right left huh hmm
left right left right right right left
left I did it
big
what I just did what the hell did I just
did I went to a bad place I went to a
very bad place do I even have a map for
this area no I do not what the hell is
that why do i why am i interested in
something that's screaming at me you
sound a lot better than the other one
I'll go to you
dissonance Oh much better
is that a good sign or a bad sign I
don't beautiful beautiful thing why do I
keep seeing things
I do not know if I'm doing the right
thing here wait a minute there's a tone
playing in the background ah I did it
man yours your backup singers need some
real work there they're not doing too
hot
hi okay what in the hell what was the
point of that did I die okay okay what
am I still alive I got it
whoo I got it I guess and somehow I'm
still loving pretty sure she ate me and
that was my blood maybe that's what the
doll said that was the price okay here
we go then this yes here that's do that
do the thing do the thing that's the
thing I got Dwight have it I got the
thing what do you want me to do is the
thing I got the singing I got did it
melt
is that what's problem was it melted oh
no can't have it melted in my hands
there's gotta be a thingy I got I
thought I had a key
but I did not cuz it's a douche oh ah
so I saw okay so I did that wrong no
okay let me go back and look at the
stone that's what I need I need to draw
the stones I need a drawn-out Chavo
Chavo Chavo trouble Shaba
okay that was one of them and then there
was another one around here somewhere oh
okay so I got you here the first one go
dope dope dope dope yay okay and then
the other one yes oh there's three God
how do I get through the thing then I
don't know oh you're not telling me any
secrets I don't know which one for me
how do I get to there so is there
anything here I need hi
well hi there hey friend you I don't
know what you are I don't know if I want
her are you a camel underwater are you a
giraffe in need what are you are you the
oh oh I just click-and-drag you that
doesn't make it okay
that's disturbing are those the things
from Princess Mononoke do I need to pick
why would I need to pick oh I don't know
I don't know what you want from me I
didn't know I needed to click and rip
what is happening no seriously what's
happening right now I don't know how to
solve your puzzle here Brad you are some
kind of disturbing and I don't like you
why did that turn into blood what Oh
so the mei-ling's were murdered by their
mothers often unmarried women who had
been left to fend for themselves
well that's creepy as hell but what oh
hi hi there okay that's cool and all but
why was that in my book really would
like to know that so I need to find all
the mei-ling's why do I need to find
them so they're lost in the woods are
you telling me I need to go find him Oh
ding-dong okay then I'll be right back
just gonna go run on a baby ghost
hunting errand
oh that's blood oh that is so much blood
why is it covered in blood why would it
why the hell would it be covered in
blood okay good hi
aren't you fun Oh summer summer summit
okay I got ya you're wrigley one ain't
ya why are we gonna do this
oh this is not cool
oh stop wriggling you weirdo okay well
that's another one good for me I'm the
best I can find baby ghosts wherever I
go this is my superpower I think this is
one gonna be in my house I bet one's
gonna be in my house
hi well that's new why was oh oh I get
it
oh I see okay you're coming with me
squiggly you're coming with me I gotta
give you to the magical horse in the
lake because that's that's normal haha
okay this is fun time fun time
alrighty then where's the last bloody
baby this way see if he's in the
windmill which isn't equally also oh
yeah he's in the windmill oh oh god why
is it dripping why is it dripping why is
it dripping can I look up please
oh that's lovely and all but how do I go
up further oh I get it
okay I see I did not know that I need
whoa whoa there ease up on that you
douche
oh I pirate what you wriggle and
squiggle and jiggle
we giggle jiggled squiggle you're one of
the Wiggles alright I solved your
wonderful puzzle there mr. ocean horse
man River horse the horse river either
way that was fun can we never do that
again
okay oh I think I did a band so why
would you do that what was your last oh
god damn it what is that what what it's
a fire oh my god it's a fire that can
guide me along my way all right but
either way I've been playing this a bit
too long I got to cut it here thank you
all so much for watching this game is
intriguing me to no end it's slightly
terrifying got some good jump scares in
there
creepy crawly creepypasta levels of
creepy don't know what the hell is going
on still but either way thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done check out
among the sleep outlast any other
playthrough that you want me see you to
do a long we were let's play up it
either way thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
Oh
you
the board back up this okay well that's
not good
what in the world is I don't know okay
come on tomorrow